sex education the conversation animals
in zoos refuse to let you not have now
with some kids going back to school next
week it is guaranteed that at some point
over the next school year you'll hear
stories like this local parents are
outraged tonight over the pictures that
their children saw in sex ed class some
parents say that the material which
includes descriptions of sex acts and
infections is simply too graphic for
middle schoolers a father is upset after
his 13 year old showed him a poster
hanging on a classroom door a poster
listing sex acts parental anger over sex
ed is as much a staple of the school
year as Square pizza
and one kid coming back from summer
vacation with a mustache he's way too
proud of that that's a ghost mustache
Luis it looks like the real mustache
died on your face so so we tried this
week to find out what sex ed looks like
in America right now but that turns out
to be a surprisingly difficult question
to answer now in the past depending on
how old you are sex education may have
been little more than watching films
like this every so often I get a strong
sex urge and the only way I can take
care of it is to masturbate Jorge I'm
really pleased that you can tell me
about this perhaps it's because we've
known each other for so long my name is
John extent for me it all started when I
went bowling with Judy today I shoulda
known something was different as soon as
she got a strike she's usually such a
rotten bowler so what's so different
about I got my first period today
it means that blood is flowing out of my
uterus okay okay okay first that is some
incredible misinformation menstrual
blood is not some sort of uterine HGH
that makes you amazing at bowling and
second and this is true the young man in
that video is Jonathan banks Mike from
Breaking Bad does not provide the basis
for the prequel to better core soul I'm
going to be extremely disappointed
teaching sex addict in schools is really
important for obvious reasons no parent
wants to talk to their kids about sex
and no kid wants to talk about sex with
their parents that is why when you're
watching a movie together and there's a
sex scene everyone becomes motionless
and silently begs for the merciful
release of death and kids have good
questions that need good answers The
Times recently ran an article with a
slideshow of questions kids wrote on on
cards to a sex educator including why is
the boy's penis shaped like an arrow is
it okay to be gay and how long do I have
to wait to have sex I'm excited to it to
which the answers are its engorged with
blood yes and can you at least wait
until the end of class but perhaps the
most poignant question was will this go
well for me because after looking into
sex ed programs this week the answer
depends quite a bit on where you live
there is no required standard for sex ed
in this country in fact only 22 states
mandate to the kids receive it and only
13 require that the information
presented be medically accurate which is
crazy you wouldn't accept a history
class not being historically accurate
Prince started the American Revolution
in 1994 and his Purple Reign lasts until
the present day class dismissed
what we essentially have a weird
patchwork system that varies wildly and
not just from state to state but from
district to district and even from
school to school in fact one oh hi oh
newscast
try to find out what kids in their area
were learning and hit a brick wall the
state has no absolutely none sex ed
guidelines so each school district
decides what's best for whatever kid
many school districts don't want to talk
about it at all you see students pulled
every school district in for Southwest
Ohio counties the majority wouldn't tell
us what they teach and when they teach
it even though all this is supposed to
be public information and that's really
not good because two teenagers shouldn't
have completely different levels of sex
ed just because they're in two different
school districts at tonight's football
game if it's when Lakewood High and
Middletown high not only are they bitter
rivals one of those teams has no idea
what a diaphragm is let's play ball
let's play ball but but while it is hard
to find out what kids are learning in
some cases it is possible to find out
what they are not learning for instance
in Mississippi while you can talk about
contraceptives the law prohibits condom
demonstrations in class that means no
condom on a banana no condom on a
cucumber no condom on a zucchini and
that's terrible partly because it's fun
putting condoms on produce but mainly
because Mississippi ranked number two in
the country in teen pregnancy rates now
thankfully this situation has inspired
some creative alternatives what this
former teacher described how to use a
condom without directly using a condom
because I want to make sure that there's
room for my toes when I'm engaging in
Shu activity take your stock and you
want to roll it all the way down it's
not perfect no if you can't get a sock
out of the packaging you don't then lose
your foot for a minutes and need to
think of Rihanna to get it back but its
back but but Mississippi's restrictions
are just the beginning here in eight
states there are laws considerably
limiting what teachers can say about
homosexuality to their students
meaning the answer to that kid's
question is it okay to be gay could be a
shrug or a lot worse and Utah's law
prohibits any instruction in the
intricacies of intercourse for reasons
that one state legislator explained
those are the things we do not want to
be taught in our schools those are
things that should be taught in your
home what taught in your home here is an
exchange that has never happened how are
you so good at sex I was home-schooled
and it's in certain districts around the
country the only sex ed you might
receive is abstinence only which you may
think of as a relic of the past but it
is still very much around Congress
recently increased federal funding for
abstinence only education from the from
about fifty to seventy-five million
dollars per year and at least part of
that money gets matched by the states
which means that students are still
being exposed to abstinence centered
programs but we've names like wait which
stands for why am i tempted go ape or
abstinence protects everyone and no
screwing around which I presume stands
for no one should copy like regularly
except when did individuals and now
reach around occasionally ultimately not
disastrous
and here's here's a taste of a video
from that last program if you have sex
outside of one permanent monogamous and
monogamy does not mean one at a time
that means one partner who has only been
with you you have sex outside of that
context and you will pay boys if there's
a girl throwing herself at you if she's
the one pressuring you for sex if this
is a girl that's dressing in that manner
that's saying not only of you but the
rest of the world take me now I got a
little word of advice for you run from
the screw run I did not say what go away
slowly
I said run from her in fact uh don't
even bother running boys just cut your
dicks off girls are snake charmers and
it's time to murder your snakes murder
them now do it do it
and what abstinence is a healthy choice
that many teams will make either by
choice or as I can attest by
circumstance
only thing you teach and not just
because many studies question its
efficacy the fact is according to the
CDC most Americans have more than one
sexual partner in their lifetime and the
average age at which people begin having
sex is around 17 so just saying don't do
it is not practical and even when they
do teach sex ed schools can teach it
with a strong bias we found a company
which offers schools two versions of the
same video on contraception version B is
labeled as being non-judgmental take a
look look no one ever said being a
teenager is easy you have to face a lot
of important decisions but no decision
is probably more important than the one
you'll make about becoming sexually
active some of you may already be
sexually active but still a lot of you
are not having sex yet you could be
waiting for marriage the right person or
maybe you're just not ready to take on
this very serious responsibility right
now cool oops
thumbs up those 30 year old actors
dressed like teenager from the 90s make
some very good points however however
version a which is non non-judgmental
goes in a slightly different direction
see if you can spot it look no one ever
said being a teenager is easy you have
to face a lot of important decisions but
no decision is probably more important
than the one you'll make about becoming
sexually active as a teenager you're
expected to wait until you're married
before you become sexually active until
then
abstinence is the only option that's
acceptable to your family your school
and your community well hold on then why
do they even keep the first part about
it being a decision at all they should
have just said no decision is more
non-existent than the one you don't get
to make about sex
also remember God is watching you
masturbate and the fluids coming out of
your genitals are actually his tears you
may
who's sad but they're very fact two
videos with the same title but very
different messages exist shows just how
hard it can be to find out what's going
on with sex ed where you live and this
is not even accounting for guest
speakers that schools can bring in to
augment their program remember the woman
from no screwing around that's Pam
stencil and her website claims she
speaks to half a million young people
each year presumably like this here's
the line over which you can't step
absolutely no genital contact of any
kind
that's hand to genital mouth to genital
genital to genital oral sex which is
mouth to genital is sex and if you have
ever stepped over this line you've
risked disease and you need to get
tested and don't you dare don't you dare
tell anyone you're a virgin why why are
you trying to yell the horniness out of
teenagers throw programs like hers are
so relentlessly anti sex you could
easily come away thinking the adult
world is just an endless barrage of
unwanted dicks which incidentally was
the original slogan for tinder
stanzin is not alone Shelley Donohue
currently speaks at schools around the
country she likes to show the dangers of
more than one sexual partner by
describing women as a piece of tape and
then sticking the tape to the arms of
multiple boys until this happens how
many partners do we have before we get
married on average in America yeah so
can you imagine what's gonna start to
happen to the tape it's gonna lose its
bonding power her point is the tape is
used so much it becomes damaged which
doesn't even consider the possibility
that the tape might be perfectly happy
and have had a good time or that maybe
some guys like take that already knows
how to stick when they meet them but but
this idea that sex is something which
devalues those who've had it
particularly women crops up again and
again non virgins can be likened to a
used toothbrush or a chewed up piece of
gum and then there is this video in
which a non virgin on her wedding night
is compared to a dirty shoe my sneakers
business it looks like the entire
football team has been in these things I
made them all wear socks socks but shell
socks don't protect my heart you can
still get foot fungus with sauce I wish
I could go back in time and make a
commitment to be abstinent until
marriage that is heartbreaking and not
just because he's shaming his wife but
because Michelle socks don't protect my
heart might be the funniest line ever
delivered on this show and we didn't
write it
and that that kind of message can be
hugely damaging to anyone who hears it
especially survivors of sexual assault
like Elizabeth Smart who was kidnapped
and assaulted at the age of 14 and you
may recognize one of the metaphors she
remembers one of her teachers using she
said imagine you're a stick of gum and
when you engage in sex that's like
that's like getting chew and then if you
do that lots of times it's gonna become
an old piece of gum and who's going to
want to rock through that
well that terrible but nobody should
ever say that but for me I thought oh my
gosh I'm not chewed up piece of gum
learning nothing would have been better
than learning that it's not a great
reflection on her teacher that kids who
were sick that day got a better
education than she did and the sad thing
is sex ed when done well can do so much
good but when it's done badly it can do
real harm take consent a recent survey
found college students were confused
about certain aspects of it for instance
when asked whether another person
undressing getting a condom or nodding
established consent for more sexual
activity at least 40 percent said yes
and at least 40 percent said no and that
ambiguity is a problem because sex is
like boxing if both people didn't fully
agree to participate one of them is
committing a crime and abstinence heavy
messages do not help this they spend so
much time on the importance of saying no
they can leave out what informed
enthusiastic consent looks like or even
worse suggests that it's all one party's
responsibility like in this video from a
program called sex smart about fending
off unwanted advances maybe we should
have sex you know to prove our love for
each other do you really think we're
ready yeah oops that didn't work each
other
no does that mean no yes
one more try this time say it like you
mean it
each other no way finally maybe we
should just get to the concert wait what
they were already late for a concert but
he felt there was still time to have sex
that is a teenage boy with a very
accurate sense of his abilities but much
much much more to the point it's good
that that girl was being taught that she
has the power to say no but nowhere in
the video do they point out that that
guy should have been a lot better at
hearing it and it is weird to gloss over
something so appalling it's like that
moment in Greece when Kenickie sang tell
me more tell me more did she put up a
fight that's the point they should have
stopped the whole song and gone wait
what what the did you just say what is
wrong with you Kenickie what is what
you're a monster and you look 40 and
when kids graduate high school without a
full understanding of consent
you are abetting an already troubling
culture where a bunch of frat guys can
march around Yale feeling completely
comfortable yelling out this just a
quick reminder there Yale's acceptance
rate is six point three percent so who
the are they turning down I would
hate to hear their chants and the
problem is that is not an isolated
incident last year fraternities at both
Texas Tech and LSU will caught using the
same slogan it's become something you
hear on college campuses as often as I'm
thinking of switching majors or why is
James Franco here
here is the thing there is no way we'd
allow any other academic program to
consistently fail to prepare students
for life after school and human
sexuality
unlike calculus is something you
actually need to know about for the rest
of your life
and maybe you and your family live
somewhere that has good sex ed in which
case congratulations but if you don't
this video is for you look no one ever
said being a teenager is D did you have
to face a lot of important decisions but
no decision is probably more important
than the one you'll make about becoming
sexually active and if you do there's a
few things you should definitely know
this is a penis this is a vagina this is
a head and this is a but you can mix as
many of these as you feel comfortable in
hand and mouth would be you could this
is the clitoris and these are the
testicles they make sperm that's pretty
much it if you want to be abstinent
that's fine if you don't want to be
absent
that's also fine abstinence is like
being a vegetarian people should respect
your choice
some people might make fun of you those
people are safeguard against
STDs is protection unless you already
have an STD in which case you're gonna
need medicine or some fun fact the
ancient Egyptians put crocodile dung
mixed with honey inside a vagina to
prevent pregnancy they're all dead now
here's how you put a condom on a banana
oh this is a lot less curvy than I'm
used to
this is an IUD an IUD goes inside a
woman's body and prevents pregnancy from
taking place
they can stay inside you for up to ten
years which is a lot considering most
guys in high school can only stay inside
you for a minute or two to up here's a
bunch of other forms of birth control
this is actually simple if someone
doesn't want to have sex with you don't
have sex with them
if you think you might be able to
persuade someone to have sex even though
they don't want to don't so if you're
not sure if someone wants to have sex
with you ask even if you're kind of sure
if someone is pretty drunk they might
not be able to give consent and remember
you can always say no even if someone
wants you to do a sex thing you're not
comfortable with you have the right to
refuse say I don't care if it's a birth
defect I don't want you to put your
finger in my butt okay real quick couple
funny things most people will get HPV is
both technically true and what you tend
to hear right before someone gives you
HPV if you call it a hoo-ha you are not
ready for sex food is your friend
believe me if you get a chance to have
sex with this man
go for it this safe word is Putin Annie
a woman who's had sex is not like a
dirty shoe a woman who's had sex is like
a a shoe with laces completely normal
and finally in this isn't for you anyone
ever tells you that getting your period
makes you better at both
[Applause]